Toi et ta mère aussi un verre de glace
le jeu du chat est toujours là mais mabilu ta mère et elle
La ville natale de ma mère et Nhu viennent ici est aussi meghi
mais viens ici grand mais stupide, qui est-ce
Saviez-vous que vous êtes amoureux de vos parents maintenant ?
qu'elle déteste la mère de MU mais la sienne et
Je veux y aller mais j'aime l'écrire
Ma soeur inclut le propre poisson de son oncle
Et qu'est-ce que cela signifie de rire à haute voix?
Ma mère dormait bien aussi et buvait du Ba Cam ai
critiquer ses propres fils
puis crone le téléphone ici et là si vous le faites
Mangeons la nourriture pour bébé maintenant parce que c'était il y a juste un moment
Boire de l'argent comme ça, Hoa Bi et melon
Je suis allé filmer avec Ky et je me suis réveillé de mon rêve
il y a trois fées dragons qui attendent
Quand le clip est disponible, j'irai demain
Quand il est allé manger du poisson stupide pour la première fois, son fils a dit
Merde et celui-ci doit partir
les gens, mi mi mi mi, mi mi mi, ainsi que
fabuleux venir ici pour bien pêcher mais
La belle-mère que Mme Ngo aide lorsqu'elle demande de l'aide
dis quelque chose de pluvieux et aussi cutolo
kompaniya OOO Luka modric hein
[musique]
o0o